Let's now get into a few practical examples of how you can use Tick Recorder within your
project.
So we'll look at some vehicle performance capture first.
So for this example, we're using the vehicle template map.
You can see that there's an SUV vehicle in the scene, which is the BP SUV, which you
can drag and drop into the level here.
You need some kind of input device.
I assume you have some kind of keyboard and mouse attached, but if you're working on,
say, a mobile device at the moment, just make sure you have some kind of external peripherals
plugged in that allow you to control this car.
So maybe you have some kind of game controller plugged in as well.
That would also be fine.
So when we drag and drop in the car, we can add the SUV to the source here.
Again, you could either click on source and select the BP SUV.
Or as we previously said, you can drag and drop from the world outliner to get the SUV
in there.
And you can decide what vehicle data you're recording based on the record properties that
are listed.
So we have seven different options that you might want to look at there.
Then it's mainly a case of hit and record.
Once you have your Tick Recorder open, again, we have this big red button that we can hit
record.
The countdown will play.
If you change the countdown settings, maybe it'll go from a different number, but you'll
essentially get a three, two, one.
Then you'll just be able to drive around, capture whatever information you want and
then hit stop.
And then the take will save and then you'll be able to open it within Sequencer.
So when you have this recording saved, again, dependent on your naming conventions, as we
talked about with the Tick Recorder settings, you'll find your sequence nested within whatever
parameters you set within the content browser.
So therefore we can locate this and load up the performance data.
So once we've loaded the sequence, you can see that we've got our SUV here.
And then if we want to use this as an animation for later in the project, we just want to
zero out any transforms inside this capture data as the vehicle uses root motion animation.
So the skeletal mesh will move away from the root location.
So if you want to follow the vehicle, you can select the mesh in the viewport.
From the details panel here, you can see that we've got the BP.
You can select the vehicle mesh component, hit F to focus on the SUV, which F on the
keyboard is a shortcut to focus.
And then you'll be able to track that vehicle within your recorded data.
But essentially that's how you would capture vehicle.
Nice, straightforward.
Just have a play around with the various setups and especially with the information that you
may want to record within that sequence.
Because again, it will give you a lot of power, especially in post if you're trying to add
certain elements or effects, for example.
They've all been captured live for use later on.